avez-vous sauté de joie pas certains
après ce que vous avez vu pendant 90
minutes les Bleus sauvent les meubles
imbus partout contre la Tunisie il a
fallu l'apparition d'Antoine Griezmann à
la dernière minute du temps additionnel
pour que les Bleus s'en sortent avec un
match nul on va débriefer tout ça ici en
salon dans le salon du Figaro Arthur
Berda les services politiques merci
d'être ici
des sports merci
toujours avec nous rédacteur en chef du
figaro.fr bon
un partout Vincent roseron vous avez
raté le but d'Antoine Griezmann
vous êtes sortis vite pour être avec
nous et vous ne l'avez pas vu vous avez
vu ce qu'il s'est passé avant et c'était
pas glorieux hein
alors sachez que étant un bon
journaliste et que je suis bien les
choses j'ai quand même regardé sur mon
téléphone donc j'ai vu ce but d'Antoine
Griezmann sur mon téléphone mais
effectivement pas en direct puisque je
dois quitter le stade un peu en avance
et oui effectivement avant ce but en
fait avant les avant les entrées les
habituels titulaires on sait quand même
ennuyé faire lors de ce match
pardon je me permets le but vous ne
l'avez pas vu mais est-ce que de là où
vous êtes vous l'avez entendu est-ce que
les supporters ont explosé est-ce que le
stade a explosé lorsque ce but a été
marqué
[Musique]
taper rabios sont rentrés ça a été quand
même mieux au moins dans la possession
de balle et Dembélé donc ça a été ça à
ce niveau là je pense qu'il y en a
certains qui ont qui n'ont pas marqué
pour aujourd'hui voire même qui ont dit
alors Coupe du monde sauf coup dur je
pense à Fofana qui a été
cataclysmique je pense à gaine 12y qui a
été fantomatique et tout il a joué je
vérifie
non non il y en a mais vraiment Fofana
sur le but il a eu un passage au final
un moment donné pendant cinq ou six
minutes où il a perdu tout ce qu'il a
touché et ça débouché une finesse sur
sur le but de caseries ça a été 5
minutes en enfer pour lui c'est lui qui
s'arrête complètement
de jouer sur un contre
la charnière centrale recule et puis une
charnière
le but de l'équipe de France n'a pas été
retenue pardon
ça a été revu à la vidéo et donc la
Tunisie c'est imposé un but à zéro voilà
sur la diffusion alors sur la diffusion
de TF1 sur la diffusion de TF1 on a
coupé et ils ont rendu l'antenne mais on
a vu l'arbitre qui se tenait la fin du
match donc non non c'est ce qu'on a cru
mais en fait c'était une demande vidéo
TF1 a rendu l'antenne mais la Tunisie a
bien remporté cette rencontre voilà ça
c'est le alors là c'est
extraordinaire les joueurs avec ton déco
donc pour les internautes qui nous
suivent voilà le direct on découvre
cette info exactement en Ligue des
Champions je crois c'était pas
l'Atletico de Madrid
que ce que l'on voit d'accord
Griezmann et hors-jeu au départ de
l'action il se replace derrière la ligne
le ballon lui est pas assez de lui je
joue pas le ballon non exactement action
de jeu je crois maintenant et euh dans
un deuxième temps mais
ça va être le débat ça va être le grand
lui a adressé et que bon
donc ça veut dire que nous sommes à 1,0
alors Thibault
ça veut dire que donc la Tunisie pas
réussi l'un de ces deux objectifs ce
soir c'est ça elle avait le choix entre
deux premières historiques la première
c'était bat l'équipe de France et la
deuxième cerise sur le gâteau c'est se
qualifier bon elle est pas qualifiée
elle sera peut-être pour la prochaine
fois en revanche bat l'équipe de France
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de la Tunisie que qu'elle qu'elle vient
à bout de l'équipe de France vous savez
ce qu'on va faire reprenons
vous êtes déçu l'équipe de France
à la Tunisie bon bah alors là on est
dans la catastrophe on va débriefer tout
ça évidemment vous réagissez alors vous
savez quoi ce sont les internautes qui
m'ont prévenu en disant que le but n'est
pas retenu la Tunisie a gagné sur Le
Figaro.fr certains de regarder
évidemment sur sur Youtube et ils ont vu
la même chose que nous finalement parce
que évidemment on a tous regardé le
match sur TF1 et TF1 lorsque la première
chaîne de France a rendu l'antenne peut
être un peu vite l'arbitre était en
train d'écouter ce que lui disait ses
assistants vidéos qui ont donc annulé ce
but d'Antoine Griezmann bon que retenir
de cette rencontre on va faire un
point précis sur des champs notamment
ses choix Fred Picard vous retenez quoi
de ce match et ben pour reprendre donc
si on puisse qu'on reprend le fil c'est
par rapport à ce que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure ce qui est très étonnant donc
c'est de se dire qu'on a pas de
profondeur de banc
que ce qu'a fait Didier Deschamps
n'essayant de d'avoir une équipe B on a
même pas une équipe B je suis d'accord
avec ce que des Cédric tout à l'heure on
a des joueurs comme Fofana quand même
qui se regardent jouer il a fallu
attendre à 70e minute pour avoir trois
titulaires qui rendent pour donner un
peu de rythme à cette équipe donc il y a
quand même deux univers très très
différents je trouve ça dangereux parce
que une coupe du monde c'est long on
peut se passer n'importe quoi on l'a vu
ce matin à Marcus qui devait rentrer
Marcus Thuram qui devait rentrer malade
il rentre pas ça veut dire
qu'intitulaire peut être blessé c'est à
dire qu'il descend n'a pas de réserve
parce que là on a vu quand même une
équipe très très loin c'est ça et Bruno
Barni alors lui sur Youtube me dit la
France n'a pas forcé ni fait jouer les
meilleurs dès le départ
Vincent roseron sur place bon vous avez
entendu un but un but fantôme mon cher
mon cher Vincent vous êtes avec un
supporter bien habillé alors par contre
c'est quelqu'un qui a vu
alors chez quelqu'un qui a vu le but et
alors ce but il était valable ou pas
pour moi il était valable on était juste
en face je sais pas où ils ont retrouvé
le hors jeu mais après ça a été décidé à
l'avare on regardera ce soir à la télé
en rentrant mais pour moi il y avait bu
et globalement vous avez trouvé comment
c'est français des gens quand même la
première mi-temps c'était très difficile
mais c'est souvent ça quand on a gagné
les deux premiers matchs le troisième
des champs il nous a habitué à ça il
fait jouer tous les remplaçants mais ça
ça manque de d'efficacité et de et de
maîtrise et de maîtrise c'est vrai
qu'après quand les titulaires sont
arrivés on a senti que ça ça allait un
peu mieux quand même ah il y avait une
grosse différence il y a beaucoup plus
de justesse technique et on retrouvait
la qualité de jeu qu'on avait vu dans
les deux premiers matchs bon le bilan de
tout ça est-ce que on est quand même
satisfait de la calife première place
c'est assuré où on est un peu déçu de ce
qu'on vient de voir non on venait on
venait tranquillement au match c'était
la qualification était en poche et
c'était juste pour se faire plaisir sans
pression et pour tout le monde puisse
jouer et s'exprimer sur le terrain donc
tu es bien oui les titulaires ils vont
dormir tranquille ce soir j'ai
l'impression parfait par contre c'est un
peu dommage pour les Tunisiens parce que
dans l'autre match c'est l'Australie qui
a gagné donc malgré le résultat il passe
devant dommage effectivement malgré
l'exploit merci beaucoup en tout cas
bonne soirée voilà donc les Tunisiens on
l'a dit mais ça vous allez dire au
plateau aussi tout frais de la de la
qualification 8e mais malheureusement
l'Australie a gagné Patrick votre ami
supporter Vincent qui s'allume le
parcours des Tunisiens qui oui
malheureusement devait gagner et espérer
un match nul en face dans l'autre
rencontre entre le Danemark et
l'Australie ça n'a pas été le cas les
Australiens sont donc qualifiés en 8e de
finale on y reviendra parce que c'est
une petite surprise Cédric que
retenez-vous de ce match vous là d'un
point de vue général et après je vous
préviens on fait le procès Didier
Deschamps et je serai procureur je vais
pas le rater je vais te pragmatique bon
déjà je retiens la première place ça on
va dire c'est le seul aspect positif
aussi les 20 dernières minutes ou quand
les titulaires sont rentrés on a vu que
qu'ils étaient toujours en jambes après
je suis je suis assez d'accord avec
avec Fred quand il analyse alors on peut
analyser deux façons le fait de les
avoir tous mis ensemble c'est pas
forcément leur faire un cadeau il y
avait peut-être certains qu'il faut pas
enterrer parce que si on les met avec
les titulaires juste sur un poste
spécifique je pense qu'ils pourront
peut-être un cama vinga au milieu de
terrain enfin il y en a peut-être qui
ont encore leur mot à dire maintenant il
y a eu quand même il y a quand même eu
des contre-performances qui sont à ce
niveau là enfin vraiment Fofana je pas
je veux pas accablé un joueur en
particulier mais dans l'attitude l'état
d'esprit ce qu'il a montré techniquement
physiquement c'est c'est pas possible
vous voyez le classement de ce groupe D
la France est donc en tête à la
différence de but + 3 l'Australie se
qualifie donc avec une différence de but
négative à la Tunisie et je trouve donc
à la troisième place un Danemark très
décevant je lis ce que nous disent nos
internautes il peut faire la VaR après
le coup de sifflet final voilà ce que
nous demande Paul Carsenac c'est vrai
qu'annuler le but après le coup de
sifflet final c'est baroque nous dit
Fred alors attendez on sait pas parce
que on a entendu un coup de SIFF est-ce
que c'était la fin du match enfin il
faut toujours rester prudent et on aura
au fur et à mesure on va revoir au
revoir toutes ces images et on aura plus
d'infos évidemment je pense que c'est
possible parce que de bons souvenirs
de Madrid en face de groupe récemment en
Ligue des Champions
où il y a eu un penalty raté à la
dernière seconde l'arbitre siffle la fin
du match d'accord ils se rendent compte
qu'en fait il fallait faire retirer le
penalty là il marque j'ai plus le
précisément le scénario en tête mais
c'est déjà passé quelque chose comme ça
en Ligue des Champions cette Var nous
étonnera toujours Arthur Berda vous
retenez quoi de ce match vous à part que
je vous ai vu bâiller les Marseillais je
vais essayer d'en tirer un enseignement
pour l'avenir puisque tout a été dit
plus ou moins sur le match les 90
minutes auquel on vient d'assister en
revanche peut-être que ce match c'est
plutôt un espoir qu'un enseignement j'ai
bon espoir que ce match il vienne finir
de convaincre Didier Deschamps de
refaire ce qu'il a fait durant les deux
premiers matchs Didier Deschamps jusqu'à
présent on s'ennuyait à tous les matchs
en 2018 on s'est beaucoup ennuyé il y
avait cette culte de la gagne et du
résultat mais on s'ennuie avec ça c'est
faux
non mais c'est faux ça suffit et on a
joué ça c'est un manque et l'équipe de
ce que les gens comme vous qui sont
blasés par cette équipe de France
veulent faire veulent répondre et bien
alors moi je vous mets un des plus
grands mal de l'histoire des Bleus 4
épisode 2 journal la Coupe du Monde
l'Argentine le scénario qui rend le
match
qu'un but
sur une possession de balle excusez-moi
tu as 37,5 l'Argentine c'est un scénario
complètement fou c'est Benjamin Pavard
qui sort une une seconde
je m'ennuie avec le jeu des champs que
j'ai connu aussi à Marseille et avec
lequel je m'ennuyais déjà à Marseille
même si il a ramené des titres 18 ans
après il n'empêche que sur les deux
premiers matchs auquel on a on a eu le
plaisir d'assister dans ce dans ce
Mondial le jeu était très différent
c'était nettement plus porté vers
l'avant nettement plus porté vers le jeu
nettement plus porté vers
la technique l'animation offensive etc
ça a fait du bien c'est porté par radio
Griezmann ce que Cédric tout à l'heure
rabiog Griezmann Dembélé Mbappe et puis
la pointe Giroud en pointe j'ai bon
espoir que ce match finisse de le
convaincre que c'est dans ce sens-là
qu'il faut plutôt aller parce que sinon
ce soir ce soir on se serait dit le
contraire si le but était n'avait pas
été invalidé qu'est-ce qu'on aurait dit
des chances à lui montre bien qu'en fait
il peut il arrive toujours on s'ennuie
durant le match mais à la fin les Bleus
sauve les meubles on a le match nul ça
sauve la première place pas seulement la
différence de but puisque là c'est le
cas finalement
je je savais que c'est une défaite j'ai
encore du mal ouais on a commencé
l'émission en se disant que c'était
match nul mais oui j'ai bonne espoir
c'est pour ça que je veux dire un espoir
plutôt qu'un enseignement quel est un
impact sur la suite de ce Mondial et sur
Didier Deschamps je pense qu'il en est
convaincu des champs parce que bon déjà
c'est vu si il a mis tous ses joueurs au
repos c'est que déjà il sentait
Cédric votre avis m'intéresse mais celui
supporters français auprès de Vincent un
peu plus Vincent allez-y j'ai
l'impression que vous avez trouvé plus
facilement des supporters déguisés et
enthousiastes après une défaite
et ben oui et encore et encore à mes
nouvelles je vous rappelle le dernier
match c'est aussi non j'avais trouvé
Yolaine et Axel à la base qui sont avec
moi et Yohan me disait en fait à priori
c'est surtout la Tunisie qui a gagné ce
match oui moi je suis c'était un bon
match la Tunisie a bien défendu à bien
joué on a bien stressé ils ont mérité
leur victoire et les Français ils
étaient quand même très décevants en
première mi-temps et je sais pas ça
manque un peu de cohérence et tout ça et
mais après ça s'est bien ressaisir une
deuxième mi-temps et j'ai eu
l'impression que ça jouait avec un peu
de retenue mais bon la qualification
elle est là c'est bien et c'est un joli
match un bon très bon moment
on regarde quoi
[Rires]
il est blessé
indécis avec nous un match on a un
supporter alors indécis avec nous alors
vous vous retenez quoi vous retenez quoi
ce soir vous revenez la qualification la
première place ou ce match un peu
décevant la qualification
de la Tunisie
et la bonne ambiance avec ma copine
oui c'était quand même c'est quand même
un super match niveau tribune ce soir ah
c'était incroyable on a mis le feu des
deux côtés des deux côtés c'était
magnifique bon on était les Tunisiens
étaient plus que les frais étaient un
peu plus nombreux donc la voix était
bien plus élevée c'est sûr mais mais
merci beaucoup merci à vous tous
voilà voilà pour ces supporters hop là
attention va droit excusez-moi juste
voilà on nous prend en photo aussi en
même temps mais donc voilà c'est
aussi un bon match il faut quand même le
rappeler même si il faut aussi le dire
en première mi-temps ils auraient pu
nous en mettre deux ou trois si ça avait
été une équipe un peu plus qualitative
j'ai jamais entendu des supporters aussi
heureux d'une défaite qui salue tous la
victoire de la Tunisie bon la France a
quand même perdu mais bon les gens sont
pas mécontents visiblement ils ont passé
un bon moment
allez visiblement bon ils seront
peut-être là en 8e peut-être que ce
match j'espère que c'est pas le seul
match qui verront mais alors sachez que
Chris Kross notre cher Chris cross sur
Le Figaro.fr vous donne raison Arthur
ils me disent qu'on s'ennuie et Bruno me
donne raison on peut pas s'ennuyer avec
une équipe qui en finale qui vend qui
finit en finale sans prolongation ni
penalty
bon c'est un point de vue quelle équipe
a fini en finale la France quand ça en
on a eu des penalties non
on s'impose contre l'Uruguay on s'impose
contre l'Argentine contre l'Argentine
contre l'Uruguay contre la Belgique et
puis
et on a mis un sacré paquet de buts
sachez-le mais bon vous avez envie
d'être négatif j'ai bien compris allez
on parle de Didier Deschamps et vous
réagissez évidemment sur YouTube sur Le
Figaro.fr vous êtes de plus en plus
nombreux à nous rejoindre dans notre
salon on reste à doigts avec Vincent
roseron et tous les supporters qui
sortent du stade des champs s'est-il
trompé oui ou non Cédric
non non pour moi c'était c'était très
important de faire tourner c'était
important de pas prendre de risques avec
un certain nombre de joueurs importants
donc la première place était quasiment
assurée on peut pas le
condamner pour ses choix en plus bon si
Marcus Thuram a été effectivement malade
il a pas eu de chance parce que
peut-être que si on avait une attaque
avec Thuram colomanie koman peut-être
que ça aurait été Fred a eu des
informations il était bien malade bon ça
vous me confirmez un problème bon voilà
donc si vous nous rejoignez vous savez
est-ce qu'il s'est trompé d'idée
Deschamps non moi je pense pas c'est ce
que je disais tout à l'heure pour moi
c'était pour une cohésion d'équipe ils
partent ils ont 26 il y a un moment il y
a on a vu une très grosse différence
une ambiance c'est c'est un ensemble
c'est c'est un collectif c'est c'est
extrêmement compliqué
je tout à l'heure et on peut on peut
pour reparler en se disant c'est pas si
il fait jouer que l'équipe une et qui se
blesse on dira pourquoi il a fait ça
c'est plus important après on avait une
qualification au bout voilà
complètement
d'accords
là pour le coup je le défends oui il
fallait faire tourner oui la première
place était quasi assurée et puis
surtout il y a cette dimension humaine
dans un mondial et il y a des champs il
est très attaché à ça je lui en fais
plutôt crédit et ça lui a jusqu'ici
plutôt réussi il est attaché la
dimension humaine il y avait un super
papier de Baptiste des prés qui est un
collègue de de Cédric au service des
sports bien sûr
et puis raconter comment en 2018 le cas
Thauvin avait posé problème par exemple
un gars comme Thauvin qui jouait à l'OM
à l'époque avait été emmené au Mondial
c'était un peu inespéré pour lui et
qu'en fait elle veut jouer combien 15
secondes une minute c'est
je crois moins de 2 minutes en tout cas
c'est ça se joue entre moins d'une
minute et et à peine plus et à
manifestement d'après ce que raconter
Baptiste avait posé de réels soucis dans
dans le collectif
des joueurs frustrés et donc là Didier
des chances qu'il veut c'est avoir un
collectif Steve Mandanda lui est très
reconnaissant que vous n'aimez pas de ce
cadeau c'est mon endroit c'est ça
en tout cas moi j'ai pas envie de
frustrer mes coéquipiers Vincent
roserand nous attend il est avec des
supporters allez-y vous avez la main
est-ce que eux sont déçus de la défaite
des Bleus ou bon il s'en moque comme
tous ceux que vous avez dégoté depuis
tout à l'heure
et ben je vais leur demander est-ce que
vous êtes déçu de la presse-performance
de l'équipe de France un petit peu déçu
malgré tout mais bon on reste premier
donc c'est bien pour la suite quand même
alors encore des gens très pragmatiques
qui vont au je suis désolé Juliette vous
aussi vous avez vu ce match qu'est-ce
que vous en avez pensé qu'est-ce que
vous retenez à la fin ils se sont quand
même bien défendus et qu'ils ont réussi
à sauver quelques balles quelques ouais
quelques balles
on savait c'était les CDIS on en
attendait quand même pas forcément grand
chose mais on était quand même favoris
on devait le gagner ce match évidemment
bah on était favoris malgré tout mais
bon Didier Deschamps a voulu faire
changer l'équipe on voit que il y a
certains joueurs qui ont pas leur place
pendant 108e donc maintenant on va tout
donner en 8e pour espérer aller au plus
loin possible les titulaires ils vont
dormir tranquille ce soir Fofana il va
pas piquer la place de radio non non
effectivement mais bon après on sait pas
ce que des champs va nous concocter pour
les 8e on sait jamais peut-être qu'il va
faire quelques changements au vu du
match qui a eu aujourd'hui donc on verra
bien et du coup vous êtes quand même
confiant pour les huitièmes pour la
suite de la compétition malgré ce
résultat j'imagine bien évidemment on va
faire confiance à Yann à Griezmann et
puis on verra justement on les a vu
rentrer un peu plus en fin de match là
on a vu qu'il y avait quand même une
différence bien sûr ils ont apporté le
feu tout de suite d'ailleurs ils ont
marqué un but malgré ça ils étaient hors
jeu mais ils ont tout de suite apporté
le feu et la défense était tout de suite
paniqué de la Tunisie donc c'est bon
signe pour la suite super avec ben
écoutez merci beaucoup tous les deux
voilà donc encore des supporters qui
trouvent que la France n'a pas bien joué
mais quand même voilà on se satisfait
quand même de cette qualification
première place de groupe sinon c'est
vous qui jouez le supporter en colère je
sais que vous m'avez trouvé Obélix
ce qui est important je suis pas
persuadé qu'on se souvienne des matchs
nuls de 2014 qu'on se souvienne des
matchs nuls de 2018 en 8e de finale là
on l'a perdu sur un fil parce que tout à
l'heure vous disiez 90 minutes non ça il
a fallu attendre 98 minutes
voilà et une petite quelques secondes de
plus moi je suis intimement persuadé que
c'est un bon choix humain et je suis
d'accord avec Arthur même si un parisien
à marseillais dans cette salle je suis
d'accord avec Arthur je pense que pour
la cohésion d'équipe pour le il a fait
jouer après d'accord mais je vous donne
deux arguments
certains joueurs Olivier Giroud n'aura
pas joué pendant 9 jours parce que ça
peut casser le rythme
et deuxième point est-ce que après cette
belle dynamique bon bah là ce soir
excusez-moi de vous le dire je pense que
dans le vestiaire ils font pas la fête
non ils font pas la fête mais je pense
qu'il s'en sortent pas en disant bah
c'est bon on est sur une belle dynamique
là les copains qui ont joué et qui ont
pas été bon bah ils ont pas besoin et
ben peut-être je pense que les
titulaires droit dans les yeux comme
d'habitude ça les rassure les titulaires
je pense que le sport à ce niveau-là un
moment il y a aussi ses joues il y a
beaucoup de mental on a une équipe a qui
est capafé un début de coupe du monde
extraordinaire mais qui a fait le boulot
elle a fait le boulot elle a été là on a
une attaque on a un million on a une
défense et c'est solide on sent très
bien que on on pourra le revoir dix fois
le la faute de Fofana il s'arrête alors
on va pas terrestre stigmatiser un
joueur mais ils se sont tous arrêtés il
a fallu attendre 70ème minute et là à ce
moment là on a des types qui viennent
qui ont le feu et ben c'est ça qui fait
la différence et moi je suis plus
inquiet pour me dire que demain on peut
avoir des joueurs qui sont blessés et
malheureusement derrière c'est dont je
parlais mais Cédric est mieux placé que
nous pour en parler c'est la profondeur
qu'on peut avoir sur le banc je trouve
moi en revanche que sur ces 30 on n'a
pas de profondeur
c'est pas c'est pas problématique sur
cette Coupe du Monde spécifique non
c'est plus problématique que vous avez
une coupe du monde en juin juillet où il
y a une longue préparation les joueurs
n'ont pas joué là vous lui faites jouer
deux matchs après vous recoupez le
rythme là c'est comme si vous me disiez
est-ce que c'est problématique qu'à un
moment donné un joueur quand même Mbappé
n'est pas de match en semaine et qui
joue le samedi en Ligue 1 et le dimanche
en Ligue 1 ça va lui poser aucun
problème surtout que j'irai où je vois
en Italie et non en Angleterre il y a
une trêve hivernale de toute façon il
est habitué à cette période de l'année
plus ou moins c'est c'est plutôt dans un
mois
quoi maintenant mais il y a pas le
Boxing Day il joue pas à Noël en Italie
ni en France d'ailleurs et donc ils sont
l'habitude de cette je voulais juste
savoir si on pouvait par ailleurs revoir
les stats du match alors on va demander
est-ce qu'elles ont été mises à jour je
pense qu'on peut les avoir à nouveau
regardez là
on est censé gagner ce match en réalité
parce que ça c'est 5 % de possession
gagner parce qu'à mon avis les stades
sont trompeuses je pense qu'on fait les
stades 10 minutes avant la fin de la
rencontre on a pas autant de tir et pas
autant de fois
20 minutes avant la fin ça aurait été
une catastrophe
dure 90 minutes et puis quand on a
d'ailleurs plutôt 100 exactement je vais
pas m'enthousiasmer du fait qu'on aurait
dû gagner un match contre la Tunisie
Arthur on a gagné la première période
mais un match nul on tire deux fois plus
au but que que nos adversaires on cadre
plus que bon à ce jeu un peu de choses
mais on cadre plus que et on a une
possession nettement supérieur à l'heure
ça c'est un badge que tu dois gagner
quand il faut quand tu es à ce niveau de
compétition c'est un match qu'on doit
gagner on va sur le petit paradoxe qu'il
y a c'est que on perd la seconde période
où on a été meilleur avec l'entrée alors
que la première période on est on est
vraiment catastrophique
bien sûr je lis je me dis âgée il
commence à faire les notes de certains
joueurs on va y aller alors il nous
demande d'abord à quoi il sert tu rames
exactement on précise tu auras deux
méthodes titulaires il était malade
c'est pour ça qu'il n'a pas débuté et
que des champs a dû revoir une
composition un peu de briquet de broc en
mettant des joueurs pas forcément à leur
poste au dernier moment Fofana horrible
c'est ce qu'il nous dit il est d'accord
avec vous Konaté trop fébrile trop lent
bon c'est pas ça
bon qui a le plus raté allez on ouvre
les
Fofana bon Fofana
ah voilà parce que Fofana c'est un
joueur
parce qu'on paye son erreur on paye son
erreur voilà on prend le but maintenant
coman parce qu'on attendait que sur un
match comme ça ils mettent un petit mal
de crâne à Didier Deschamps dire
Ousmane Dembélé ou Kinsley coman là je
pense qu'aujourd'hui
Ousmane Dembélé il peut lui peut dormir
tranquille ce soir d'accord bon oui il
faut fana je pense que vous serez
d'accord sur le filao.fr ici dans le
salon voilà c'est un joueur mineur
Kingsley coman
il a complètement raté le coche parce
que lui il aurait pu jouer une place de
titulaire et non seulement il aurait pu
jouer une place de titulaire et on dit
aussi bien que Fofana son erreur nous a
coûté un but quand même son erreur elle
nous a coûté à vue dans l'autre sens il
aurait dû le mettre d'abord il doit bien
contrôler le ballon et ensuite et soit
il doit frapper exactement en première
intention soit il doit le contrôler et
derrière voyons qu'il le contrôle mal et
qu'il ne peut pas tirer au lieu de
s'entêter à dévisser complètement en
tout en étant déséquilibré en tombant en
même temps qu'il essaie de frapper il
doit mettre le pied sur le ballon poser
le jeu et puis lever la tête donc je
serai pardon je lis ce que nous dit
Nathan et qui vous répond on aurait dû
gagner Waterloo aussi oui mais on va
faire oui en effet vu comme ça bon euh
Didier Deschamps tu connais moi les
stades de Waterloo
c'est le problème de Fofana c'est qu'on
va effectivement cette erreur sur le but
et puis on l'a vu perdre beaucoup de
ballons toucher beaucoup de ballons et
on perdent beaucoup après il y a
d'autres joueurs qui ont fait en sorte
de pas toucher le ballon je on s'avérer
tout et à game Douzi comme ça moi
parce qu'on a la déclaration de Didier
Deschamps la première nous sommes timide
mou il est un peu de fébrilité car
certains ne sont pas à leur poste
habituel on a du déchets techniques on
perd les duels oui bilan un peu noir
mais en effet ce que je retiens surtout
les joueurs ne sont pas à leur poste
voilà c'est pour ça que je repasse
certaines choses à des champs vous avez
pas les joueurs à l'époque certains
postes déjà c'est que la sélection est
pas très bonne parce qu'il y a pas de
latéraux ça c'est un problème de base ça
c'est un problème de base on est
d'accord mais pour revenir sur sur les
joueurs
[Musique]
Mathéo le petit star marseillaise
moi je suis extrêmement déçu j'ai en
milieu de terrain quand tu as un match
comme ça
où ça doit jaillir de tous les côtés il
a 23 ans il devait faire quelque chose
au milieu Cédric a raison et enfin on
regarde le match on se dit mais en fait
surtout il veut pas avoir la balle alors
on est dans ce que dit Didier Deschamps
c'est des à la fois déchets euh d'autant
qu'avec Marseille il fait il fait preuve
d'une démo énergie exactement et qui l'a
rendu très populaire à Marseille
a une côte de popularité assez élevée
c'est ça qui est toujours rigolote
exactement et là c'est quand même c'est
quand on parle du joueur avec celui-ci
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est aussi
totalement même Griezmann rentre en
trois balles en bas là une touche de
balle exacte du rythme tout de suite
n'a pas fait ça il a pas fait ça il
était parti pour ça il avait pas
de faire ça et et il y a un moment il y
a pas d'entrain on joue sur la réserve
et plus on joue sur laserve et ben moi
il y a de confiance et un moment bah le
le système s'arrête c'est ce qu'on a
vécu et à la 70e minute et d'ailleurs on
sait tous posé la question des champs il
fait ça parce que
sinon alors là je suis d'accord avec
vous ça risque de générer un stress
collectif non mais et il est obligé de
relancer la machine parce que si c'est
un bon collectif le premier prochain
match pour relancer la machine c'est un
match et destination en direct mais ça
va être on aura les titulaires et là les
titulaires les titulaires s'il y a un
bon collectif les titulaires doit venir
soutenir les gars qui ne sont pas là
c'est c'est pas l'inverse c'est et je
crois que que c'est très important ce
que ce qu'a fait des gens humainement et
pour le groupe
je lui laisse la parole on aurait mérité
d'égalisé car on a bien fini la
rencontre pas tout à fait faux mais bon
après on a eu des difficultés de par les
choix que j'ai fait ça devrait nous
servir dans quatre jours l'objectif est
atteint maintenant on va récupérer c'est
intéressant je fais sembler à cool pas
la défaite
le sol la seule chose aujourd'hui la
seule erreur entre guillemets qui commet
mais après on n'est pas dans la vie du
groupe on sait pas exactement c'est
Benjamin Pavard
parce que là aujourd'hui je suis là vous
mettez 10 à 6 il a fait un match comme
il pouvait parce que très clairement il
a pas les qualités de camavinga ou qui
pouvait plus faire illusion sur le poste
de latéral gauche donc là on lui dit
clairement kundai on a tellement peur
qu'il prenne un carton jaune qu'on le
met pas ça veut dire qu'on veut vraiment
qu'on est soit titulaire sur le 8e de
finale et et Pavard ont même pas sur un
match comme ça ça veut dire que j'aime
pas du tout le terme coiffeur mais ça
veut dire il est même pas quoi faire
quoi
vous allez devenir vulgaire j'ai bien
senti la question la question se pose
d'autant plus que Pavard non seulement
c'est la bonne surprise de 2018
titulaire à discutable à droite et qu'il
joue le premier match mais Québec
catastrophique est exactement mais quand
Cédric dit il n'est même pas coiffeur il
était à la base titulaire carrément dans
ce Mondial c'est-à-dire qu'on part de
d'un joueur qui est là la bonne surprise
de 2018 avec on se souvient tous ceux
qu'on poteau Pavard ce but on en parlait
tout à l'heure face à l'Argentine avec
inverse la tendance et permet le plus
important
et voilà exactement et il fait un match
désastreux c'est vrai contre l'Australie
et puis derrière c'est là où en effet on
n'est pas dans l'intimité du groupe on
sait pas ce qui se passe on sait que
c'est pour ça que Benjamin Pavard est un
joueur qui a quand même un mental plus
ou moins friable on va dire donc on sait
qu'il a connu des difficultés ces
dernières années il en a d'ailleurs
parlé peut-être de de s'ouvrir a pu
avoir une vertu thérapeutique mais
malheureusement sur ce sur cette Coupe
du Monde et là je vois pas je vois pas
très bien comment Didier Deschamps
pourrait le relancer pour la suite vous
savez ce qu'on fait on va à Doha on
retrouve Vincent roseron Vincent
Claudius vous salue un des habitués du
Figaro demande si je postule pour
remplacer des champs non certainement
pas bon Vincent faites nous le bilan de
ce que vous avez vu dans cette rencontre
et puis en tribune aussi ça peut être
intéressant quel était l'ambiance
décrivez-nous tout ça
et bien effectivement l'ambiance en
tribal alors déjà on va commencer par
l'ambiance en tribune l'alliance en
tribune c'était vraiment une grande fête
les Bleus ça a commencé tout de suite
dès que j'ai le ballon ils étaient
sifflé d'ailleurs Mbappé dès qu'il a eu
le ballon quand il est rentré Bronka
énorme à chaque fois sinon pour parler
un peu du niveau de chacun du coup Steve
Mandanda a fait un match correct même si
il prend un but il avait pas eu grand
chose à faire jusque là en défense on
l'a dit dit ça se dit pas son poste qui
n'a pas fait un grand match clairement
on a bien compris que c'est pas une
bonne idée de forcément de le mettre là
Raphaël Varane un peu fébrile pas
forcément au top
Ibrahima Konaté un vrai patron pour le
coup Ibrahima Konaté il a montré que
c'était s'il y a un titulaire
aujourd'hui qui peut avoir un peu peur
pour sa place c'est ou pas mes cadeaux
parce que Ibrahima conaké ce qu'il a
fait pendant ce match c'était
impressionnant en début de match il a
calmé toutes les situations dangereuses
clairement il y avait lui et surtout
parce qu'il était sur le même côté il
était dans l'axe mais sur le son côté il
y avait dehors de Cavavin gars qui a
pris un bouillon pas possible en début
de match mais vraiment ça a été
incroyable d'ailleurs les Tunisiens
l'ont beaucoup cibler ils sont allés
beaucoup beaucoup de son côté ils ont vu
qui était fébril ils ont dit bah allez
maintenant on y va on va là mi le
terrain maintenant les mieux de terrain
on a dit au début de ce live il y avait
5 joueurs de Ligue 1 alignés et bah sur
les 5 joueurs c'est tellement dent on va
peut-être le mettre un peu à part mais
il y en a sur les quatre il y en a aucun
qui a vraiment montré les choses le
milieu gain Douzi vert tous les deux
Marseillais ça a été compliqué pour eux
pas trop de précises on a senti vraiment
qu'ils étaient ils étaient inhibé par la
pression de la Coupe du Monde on peut le
comprendre aussi mais ils sont arrivés
dans cette compétition ils sont arrivés
sur le terrain et on a senti qu'ils
avaient le peu le ballon qui leur brûlé
les gens mais ils savaient pas vraiment
quoi en faire au mieux au milieu de tout
ça on avait donc Fofana vous avez parlé
Fofana il a pas été bon du tout non plus
Fofana voilà à l'image de son but oui il
s'arrête complètement de jouer ça c'est
pas normal qu'on clairement mais surtout
on le voit et il a pas non plus été bon
sur les sur il a fait des
contre-attaques où il ne fait pas le bon
choix il a fait une ou deux contre-attag
alors je n'ai plus les limites en tête
mais où il ne fait pas le bon choix par
contre moi je mettrai quand même aussi
un bon point à Aurélien de choix mini
qui au milieu a fait un sacré boulot
toujours un travail de l'ombre mais lui
très juste techniquement il a réussi à
encaisser les chocs des autres joueurs
tunisiens parce que c'était quand même
un match physique et bon voilà il a
montré des choses sur une attaque soit
une attaque par contre
qui ne sait comment on l'a dit pas
forcément excellent mais il a montré
quelques petites choses mais clairement
les ballons sont pas forcément arrivés
jusqu'à lui aussi il faut dire mais par
contre en alcoolomanie a fait un bon
match un bon début de match il a un peu
disparu par la suite mais le début de
match de Ronald colomanie on attaque
dans une équipe qui tourne bien ça
pourrait être intéressant de le revoir
bon ce sera sûrement pas le cas mais
pour autant on a vu qu'il était capable
techniquement de faire des bonnes choses
donc voilà un peu ligne par ligne ce que
j'ai pensé et puis bien évidemment
l'arrivée des entrants
un peu raté au début Adrien rabiot mais
voilà Griezmann qui rentre ça fait la
différence tout de suite Dembélé aussi
on l'a vite senti que dès qu'ils sont
arrivés sur le sur le terrain ça a
complètement changé les choses ça a
changé les choses mais ça a pas changé
le score mon cher mars merci reprenez
votre souffle il va déjà lui dire de
sport c'est lui qui qui fait le live
texte vous le
suivez sur le figure.fr je me demande
comment vous comment vous faites pour
suivre le match et écrire ce que enfin
ça me fatigue
il faudrait que je fasse un match avec
vous pour voir
la prochaine fois mais avec plaisir mais
oui non oui bah ils ont regrette pas
clavier en fait et puis on se laisse
porter par les émotions parfois vous
réagissez sur le Figaro.fr sur Youtube
vous êtes nombreux romain courtier du
des réseaux sociaux il est avec nous
bonsoir ce soir bon on fait un petit
point sur ce qu'on a vu sur Twitter bah
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a presque plus
de
de moments chauds sur Twitter que sur le
terrain il serait même pas passé grand
chose alors voilà l'image qui a beaucoup
tourné Kylian Mbappé mort de rire sur le
banc de touche avec cette légende même
lui rigole du niveau de jeu de virer
tout gain Douzi kamavin gars en latéral
droit c'est un attentat alors évidemment
il rigolait pas pour ça mais c'est vrai
que on était à côté Cédric on s'est dit
ils ont l'air très détendu à ce
moment-là on les a vu ça c'est un peu
crispé sur les visages après mais à ce
moment-là ils avaient l'air de tous bien
s'amuser sur le banc bah de toute façon
France première du groupe qualifié
et apéro ce soir
je suis pas sûr que des champs leur
autorise après ce qu'ils ont fait allez
ils ont continué on est au Qatar de
toute façon les remplaçants sont en
train de comprendre pourquoi ils sont
remplaçants ça je pense que c'est un
constat que tout le monde peut partager
le match a été quand même assez pauvre
en occasion de but de côté français
personne n'a vraiment gagné sa place on
a hâte de voir ce que ça donne en 8e et
ces trois alors là les têtes sont un
petit peu coupées mais je pense qu'on
les reconnaît tous Griezmann Giroud
Mbappé trois êtres vous manquent et tout
est dépeuplé
implacable ils nous ont beaucoup manqué
ensuite on peut enchaîner avec ce tweet
un petit peu caustique on se rapproche
plus d'un classico CM1 CM2 avec le
ballon en mousse que d'un match de Coupe
du Monde c'est cataclysmique
vous nous rejoignez on va prendre le
temps évidemment en restant encore un
bon moment ensemble pour débriefer ce
France Tunisie pas un grand match de
foot quoi non au niveau technique on a
vu surtout on prend la période beaucoup
de passer enfin envoyé que avec autant
de joueurs qui n'ont pas le niveau
international voilà je pense que vous
les avez dû en parler je pense que la
moitié de l'équipe à pas le niveau
international l'équipe de départ je
parle et quoi oui bah ça rejoint le
tweet en fait en première période on a
vu un festival de de rater même des
joueurs les plus chevronnés Varane on
l'a vu aussi rater quelques quelques
gestes donc vraiment on a l'impression
que tout le monde était était sur le
même au même niveau et on voit ces deux
nouveaux tweets on enchaîne avec pour
moi le quoique Hist
TF1 qui rend l'antenne alors que le but
est à quelques secondes d'être annulé je
n'ai jamais vu ça je pense que je pense
que c'est c'est du jamais vu parce que
c'est toujours difficile mais c'est vrai
que donc forcément surtout allumer pour
moi c'est l'événement de ce match
beaucoup plus que ce qui s'est passé sur
le terrain c'est la plus grande chaîne
d'Europe qui ne réussit pas une
diffusion
les confrères c'est vrai que c'est
parfois compliqué on rappelle que c'est
factures joignaient Antoine Griezmann ce
qui est un but dans les arrêts de jeu à
la 98e minute que le but sembler être
validé que TF1 a acté le match nul des
Bleus a lancé son débrief à lancer la
pub et quand ils sont revenus et bien le
but avait été annulés historique le
bandeau c'était France Tunisie alors que
l'arbitre est en train de mettre le
doigt sur son oreillette je pense que là
dans le cas rigide TF1 tout le monde de
se capter fin ça dû se faire surtout
dans toutes les chaînes du monde parce
que ça c'est aller vite hein vous pensez
à vérifier tout de suite l'impression
d'entendre le coup de sifflet final
c'est ça qui nous a peut-être surpris
bon on verra d'ailleurs en tout cas je
sais pas te dire la règle est-ce que
vous la connaissez parce qu'on s'est
demandé si on pouvait annuler un but
après le après le coup de sifflet final
je sais absolument pas dites nous vous
sur YouTube sur Le Figaro.fr ce que vous
en pensez ah j'aime bien cette courbe là
voilà alors ça m'intéresse toujours ça
nous permet de voir à quel point on
s'ennuyait avant le but de waby kazry
donc pas grand chose le but refusé pour
un jeu pour le coup tout le monde voyait
qu'il y avait un jeu donc ça c'est pas
enflammé plus que ça il y a un corner
pour les Bleus avec un tout petit pic
ensuite le but de wabycaseries bon ça
c'est normal tous les supporters de la
Tunisie ce sont des chaînés ont dû
s'amuser aussi à ce moment-là et
évidemment c'était le moment de
critiquer
France ou Twitter monde comment on sait
enfin je pose peut-être une colle alors
vu les chiffres de toute façon sur un
sur un match France - Tunisie je pense
que c'était surtout la Francophonie qui
s'est mobilisé sur sur Twitter et enfin
l'énorme pics de Griezmann la dernière
minute et finalement le non but de
Griezmann puisque on a perdu
on voit ce que lors du but les twitos ce
sont des chaînés ah ça aussi ça
m'intéresse le joueur qui a fait le plus
parler de lui c'est ça exactement alors
là c'est qui le dernier match c'était de
très loin qu'il y en AP et ben
aujourd'hui qui est rentrée sur le
terrain mais n'était pas titulaire c'est
édouardo qui a Mavica très critiqué en
bleu clair
donc c'est c'est lui qui a été le plus
cité ensuite Mbappé quand même même s'il
a pas joué tout le match Jordan Vertou
et Youssoupha fana les deux milieux de
terrain alors c'était plutôt des
critiques on l'a dit Fofana pardon il
s'appelle j'ai oublié son prénom c'est
bien Youssouf ouais c'est ça autant pour
moi donc
complètement coupable sur le but ou il
reste les bras ballants et ça ça va ça
va lui porter préjudice c'est
intéressant c'est à dire que là
quasiment tous les joueurs que vous me
citez et que vous me montrez sur cette
sur cette courbe comment on dit non
c'est pas une courbe c'est un diagramide
sur ce diagramme sont des gens qui ont
été haïtés c'est plutôt des critiques là
j'imagine les tweets sur ces joueurs sur
ces deux joueurs oui cama-ling a aussi
Mbappé on peut se dire que c'était
beaucoup de tweets quand est-ce que
Kylian va rentrer Mbappé peut faire la
différence on a vu le tweet avec Mbappé
sur le banc donc tout ça compte aussi
mais à part Mappy effectivement c'est
plutôt des joueurs qui ont été critiqués
qui sont qui sont dans le top des
publicités de Eduardo camavinga qui a
finalement plutôt convaincu à gauche
alors il a touché beaucoup de gens parce
qu'il a convaincu mais en tout cas il a
assuré quoi défensivement hormis le
premier quart d'heure très compliqué
après il a été il était bon il est
plutôt bien fermé son son couloir après
offensivement il a aucun aucun
automatisme d'un intérêt j'ai pas je
l'ai peut-être vu faire deux trois
centres mais rien de rien de très
dangereux donc à ce niveau là bon il a
montré à Didier des chocs il pouvait
éventuellement dépanner s'il y avait une
catastrophe avec Théo Hernandez mais
mais il faudra me faudrait pas qu'on
fasse si il y a un Sér le client sur le
plan francif parce que là ça sera ça
sera compliqué je lis ce que nous dit
Mélanie du Québec c'est une habituée je
vous salue Mélanie au Québec on a bien
vu la révision du but avant la fin du
match voilà donc c'est peut-être un peu
emballé sur terre
et si si on peut utiliser utiliser la
barre un an après le coup de sifflet
final oui ça me permet très de de
réviser certains résultats merci
beaucoup romain bon les réseaux sociaux
toujours très présent avec nous il nous
aide tout au long de ces matchs et de
ses débrief je remercie je vous
accompagne pour les quelques graphes
qu'on a vu bien sûr voilà parce que
c'est très intéressant à chaque fois
merci Romain Vincent Merci à VOUS euh je
reviens vers vous
ce que vous avez des retours sur ce but
refusé vous êtes peut-être en contact
avec Baptiste Desprez Christophe remise
qu'est-ce qu'il s'est passé et les
supporters qui sont venus ensuite auprès
de vous qu'est-ce qu'ils vous ont
raconté
et ben ils n'en ont pas tant parler que
ça de ce but voilà vous avez eu le
premier qui m'a dit bah moi je comprends
pas vraiment ce qui s'est passé je sais
pas vraiment puisque comme vous l'avez
dit j'étais pas dans le stade au moment
du but et je n'ai pas encore de
nouvelles de nos autres journalistes
mais qui vont vous en envoyer aussi
j'imagine dès qu'ils sont en plus on
vous le dira mais on a pas vu l'image en
tout cas j'ai pas vu les ralentis et je
ne sais pas si la FIFA les a proposé vu
que les les différentes chaînes ont
rendu l'antenne et vu qu'elle rentre
l'antenne mais elle passe pas les
ralenti donc du coup c'est terminé et au
revoir
ouais c'est vrai tiens j'ai d'ailleurs
des nouvelles de Baptiste des prés
résultat logique quand on voit l'équipe
de départ les entrants n'ont pas été au
niveau certains affichons leur limite
dans une coupe du monde Vivement
Dimanche et le retour des cadres trop de
changements trop de lacunes trop de
joueurs pas au niveau un match à oublier
rien à retenir si ce n'est deux choses
choix mini et communauté sont les deux
seuls à avoir fait honneur au maillot
des Bleus trop peu pour espérer autre
chose ce soir voilà Vincent il y a du
monde encore autour de vous est-ce que
ça s'est vidé vite c'est un des nombreux
stades de DOA c'est ça
c'est ça on est à éducation City l'un
des stades dans qui est donc vous voyez
derrière moi très beau stade une fois de
plus et qui ces vidéos oui en fait les
gens partent déjà un peu avant la fin
mais ça comme dans tous les matchs de
foot pour éviter les bouchons pour
éviter les gens dans le métro parce que
on part de ces stade surtout en métro
donc pour éviter le monde et là le stade
est assez vide et vous voyez derrière
moi les gens jeunes qui sont les gens
qui indiquent la sortie du métro et ils
sont une belle armée à chaque fois pour
sortir du métro je sais pas si vous avez
déjà vu sur d'autres images mais
beaucoup beaucoup de gens pour guider
les supporters avant de partir
merci Vincent vous restez évidemment
avec nous on continue ce débrief pour
réagissez sur le Figaro.fr sur Youtube
Mathieu Morges a rejoint le figure
hostile connaisseur de foot vous pouvez
retrouver on a recouper tout à l'heure
votre petite chronique on peut la
retrouver sur le figarolive sur les
entraîneurs les plus stylés et Cédric
allier prend exemple sur Hervé Renard et
la chemise j'ai vu ça j'ai pas les
chaussures Louis Vuitton il faut que je
sois fit aussi
que vous ayez les cheveux un peu plus
longs pas bon c'est il y a du boulot
quoi mais c'est un sur les cheveux le
plus long ça va être plus compliqué mais
on va le plus dur c'est le début après
ça donnez-moi 10 ans
allez on continue à débriefer ce cette
défaite des Bleus 1 à 0 contre la
Tunisie est-ce que on peut en déduire
que cette équipe ce n'est qu'un 11 et
puis c'est tout Mathieu
visiblement c'est peut-être pas à 11 et
puis c'est tout mais peut-être un 12 13
quelque chose comme ça je trouve que
effectivement les remplaçants bon comme
on l'a dit depuis le début ont pas
forcément été très convaincant hormis
quelques-uns c'est vrai qu'il y a eu un
changement vraiment
des images du ce n'est pas le stade
parce que faut toujours expliquer à nos
internautes c'est le stade de ce soir du
match du Mexique voilà mais nous sommes
en direct au Qatar et on vous montre
toutes ces images parce que c'est
important on va évidemment se pencher
sur ce qui se passe dans ce groupe C
c'est très intéressant allez-y je vous
laisse continuer Mathieu oui donc hormis
quelques-uns comme comme Konaté
notamment bon ça a pas été très
convaincant effectivement Fofana on a on
a on va peut-être pas tiré sur
l'ambulance puisque ça parce que je
pense qu'il a compris
voilà mais bon effectivement c'est pas
c'est 11 et demi allez on va dire pour
moi il y a 13 très 13 14 joueurs
qu'en 2018 oui mais justement en 2018 on
n'a pas gagné avec on a gagné à 13 ou 14
au final il y a j'ai pas l'impression
que tous les remplaçants étaient
concernés par par l'image notamment des
phases de la phase illuminatoires au
final le 11 et j'ai l'impression qu'on a
11 qui évolutif le 1er match ce n'est
pas du tout la même compo que pour le
deuxième on peut avoir du côté ah ouais
vous trouvez en 2018 le premier match ça
peut être le même que que la compo était
pas la même que que le deuxième le
troisième il a fait tourner depuis
longtemps il n'était pas tout à fait
prêt Hernandez s'est blessé c'est aussi
pour ça que c'est un peu compliqué c'est
plus compliqué cette année mais au final
si il y a plus de blessures d'ici la fin
du Mondial je pense que l'équipe a de la
gueule quand même comment dire il y a
des faiblesses enfin il y a des il y a
des endroits qui sont un peu plus
compliqué que d'autres les postes de
latéraux on l'a vu on a vu ce soir au
milieu de terrain il y avait comme une
faillite collective aujourd'hui face à
la Tunisie il sera alors qu'en défense
centrale bon on avale pas mécano Konaté
on sait qu'on en a trois qui ont montré
des belles choses depuis le début en
compétition on attaque même si coman
aujourd'hui a pas marqué des points
quand ils rentrons le jeu
apporte quelque chose et tout je trouve
que que le mois d'I a pas été trop
mauvais faudra voir Marcus Thuram on
sent qu'il y a encore qui a quand même
des solutions mais au milieu de terrain
j'aurais bien voulu effectivement voir
au moins un Fofana ou ou ou un gain
Douzi faire quelque chose aujourd'hui
pour nous rassurer un peu parce que si
il se passe quelque chose avec rabiot ou
soitmini est-ce que ça t'étonne au final
parce que
Fofana et gain Douzi
des choses
là où on peut on peut se rassurer
peut-être un petit peu c'est que et
alors que vous voyez cette cette
déclaration de
Ibrahima Konaté qui a fait plutôt un bon
match dans ce qui ressort
Gérard de perdre on était pas au niveau
ce week-end il n'y aura pas de cadeau ce
sera un match et c'est tout oui c'est
intéressant c'est un des plus jeunes et
lui il remobilise les troupes il a pas
envie de perdre et il sait que le
prochain si ça se passe pareil merci au
revoir attention c'est un joueur
extraordinaire en interview pas langue
de bois du tout ah ouais vous l'avez
bien
il est nature il est non non ça a l'air
d'être un super mec et très drôle et qui
cesse
qui est porté sur l'autocritique aussi
ça c'est bien je vais demander à Vincent
Rozon qui est sur place on fait une
incise on parle de Ibrahima Konaté
puisqu'il vient s'exprimer vous l'avez
vu en conférence de presse comment vous
l'avez trouvé il est sympa Konaté
alors oui il est il est sympa et alors à
ce que peut être un agent un joueur
sympa en conférence de presse c'est pas
non plus un choix incroyable mais par
rapport à certains ou clairement on
s'ennuie et on sent qu'ils ont pas du
tout envie d'être là lui il est beaucoup
plus affable on va dire il est voilà il
apporte cette fraîcheur en conférence de
presse et on voit qu'il aime bien
l'exercice qu'il est qu'il est à l'aise
avec ça voilà il se sent bien et là
aujourd'hui ils sont matchs alors qu'il
n'a rien à voir avec ses conférence de
presse aujourd'hui je leur dis mais son
match est assez impressionnant surtout
en première mi-temps ou cama vinga a
pris a pris le bouillon complet pendant
les 20 premières minutes lui il a été
derrière à chaque fois pour attraper le
coup derrière
merci Vincent tiens j'ai une question de
Louis Simon qui nous parle du buteur
tunisien quel club a été formé au Abi
Khazri en Corse
est-ce qu'il a été formé à Bastia où
est-ce qu'il y avait quoi je vais
chercher il était très jeune en tout cas
moi j'ai il a il a fait ses premières
armes à Bastien oui c'est ça
junior JS Ajaccio de 95 à 2004 de 2004 à
2009 son parcours junior à Bastia et il
fait ses débuts en professionnel
je crois pas Frédéric Horn ça à l'époque
si si ma mémoire est bonne c'était une
époque Bastia avait une très belle
équipe avec des joueurs comme Michael
Essien comme un autre aussi Shao qui
bensada qui a rien fait derrière et qui
case risque et c'est top on a la
déclaration d'Antoine Griezmann il nous
parle de son but que nous dit-il sur le
centre je suis hors-jeu mais ce n'est
pas grave je lui ai dit à l'arbitre que
je n'avais pas l'intention de jouer le
centre mais le défenseur rate son geste
et c'est pour ça que je la reprends bon
il nous explique le plus important et le
match qui arrive et il est moins
pessimiste et moins engageant que Konaté
peut-être plus d'expérience du côté
d'Antoine Griezmann un discours plus
policier à la Deschamps finalement oui
bah justement mais j'ai l'impression moi
qu'au départ le match a été un peu près
la légère qu'on a vu là on a vu
l'attitude sur les bancs qui était très
décontracté on a l'impression que si
vous avez trouvé oui oui mais on n'a pas
l'impression que c'était un match de
Coupe du monde ça restait évidemment on
était quasiment sûr d'être premier mais
je pense qu'à ce niveau là chaque match
compte et je suis un peu étonné parce
que Deschamps a horreur de la défaite
c'est que sa deuxième défaite en tant
que sélectionneur en Coupe du monde
après l'Allemagne en 2014 voilà c'est
que ça deuxième défaite donc il a il a
horreur de perdre je pense quand même
qu'il sera qui sera le premier à
remonter ces trous d'ailleurs on pensait
que des champs là dans le vestiaire ça
pousse un coup de gueule justement je
pense ouais malgré tout comment vouloir
assez joueur d'ailleurs c'est ce que
nous dit Island n'étons pas trop sévère
alors qu'on ne fabrique pas une équipe
du jour au lendemain avec 9 nouveaux
joueurs c'est pas un cadeau pour eux
honnêtement c'est vrai que c'est du
style de tomber sur ses joueurs et quand
vous me disiez Fofana a pas rassuré gain
Douzi a pas rassuré s'il venait à entrer
en jeu parce que l'un ou l'autre des
titulaires est blessés ils ont dans un
collectif déjà plus huilé c'est beaucoup
plus simple quand même mais vu l'ovule
vu comment fonctionne des changes je
pense que là dans le vestiaire ça je
suis pas sûr que c'est que plus que ça
par contre le débriefing du match le
lendemain avec la là je pense que i7
s'engueuler des champs il sait bien
envoyer des pics là où ça fait où ça
fait très mal et je pense que demain le
débriefing va va piquer quelques égaux
bon on suivra ça évidemment enfin on
pourra pas trop le suivre je voudrais
qu'on jette un œil sur le groupe C parce
que on se projette maintenant bon
courage la France est qualifiée en 8e de
finale on le savait depuis quelques
jours maintenant elle est en tête de son
groupe c'était quasiment assuré mais
c'est officiel désormais et donc voici
ce groupe mettons-le en grand riad s'il
vous plaît en régie la Pologne est en
tête devant l'Argentine l'Arabie
Saoudite et le Mexique tout le monde
joue à 20h ce soir nous affront le
deuxième de ce groupe C tout le monde
peut finir deuxième vous me confirmez
vous voulez qui te dit si vous deviez
choisir vous prenez qui soyons fous
prenons l'Argentine
ils auraient le couteau entre les deux
oui bien sûr mais ils ont toujours pas
vraiment un collectif huilé voilà il se
reposeront encore beaucoup sur Messi à
côté du mariage et assez vieillissant
enfin il a 4 ans de plus mais c'est
aussi d'ailleurs donc je pense que cette
équipe est encore prenable donc d'accord
donc ça c'est ma première question vous
aimeriez voir l'Argentine
mais selon vous qui aura-t-on ce soir si
vous deviez faire deux petits pronos là
et on fait un classement rapide est-ce
que l'Argentine ne va pas battre la
Pologne non voilà et du coup la Pologne
pourrait se retrouver deuxième peut-être
c'est ça bon c'est tellement difficile
vous avez envie d'affronter l'Argentine
Mathieu vous voulez affronter qui vous
moi je pense que le meilleur scénario ce
serait l'Arabie Saoudite mais ça ça
indiquerait que l'Argentine serait
éliminé une victoire
de la plupart des deux entre la Pologne
et l'Argentine par exemple ce serait
sympa parce que les deux entraîneurs
français dont Didier Deschamps Hervé
Renard le seul autre entraîneur français
dont on a parlé il y a quelques minutes
s'affronterait donc en 8e de finale oui
je pense que ce serait sans doute dans
cette dans ce groupe l'équipe la plus la
plus probable après bon l'Argentine ou
la Pologne pour moi ça peut être aussi
des matchs pièges notamment la Pologne
attention on peut les prendre à la
légère non plus parce que ils ont avec
les vendeurs c'est quand même évidemment
Cédric vous voulez qui vous oh bah moi
je vais rejoindre forcément je pense que
l'Arabie Saoudite ça serait le bon plan
mais bon
moi je pense moi je pense qu'on va jouer
le Mexique ah donc le mec en gros vous
me dites le Mexique va gagner il y aura
un vainqueur entre la Pologne et
l'Argentine et l'Argentine l'Argentine
va gagner je pense parce que ils ont ils
ont frôlé le pire ils savent très bien
en fait un petit chrono l'Argentine
arrive en tête de ce groupe en battant
la Pologne le Mexique balarabie Saoudite
et donc l'Argentine sera première ce
soir
va passer la Pologne à la différence de
but parce que je pense que le Mexique
est tout à fait capable de gagner avec
deux buts d'écart voire même trois et
l'Arabie Saoudite peut-être que c'est
passé sur leur exploits je pense qu'ils
sont retombées sur terre et puis
vraiment les Argentins ils vont ils
savent très bien que finir premier c'est
un huitième contre l'Australie
avec tout le respect que j'ai pour pour
les soccer rose qui ont fait une
surprise extraordinaire en finissant
deuxième de du groupe de la France je
pense que l'Argentine c'est un boulevard
pour pour les cars c'est marrant parce
que il est 18h53 le match s'est terminé
il est à peu près une heure et je reçois
un message d'Axel là sur Youtube qui me
dit le but refusé point d'interrogation
lui aussi il a éteint la télé et de
changer entre temps Vincent roseron sur
place les matchs de ce soir vous allez
les suivre évidemment vous voulez
affronter qui surtout dites-nous qui euh
les Bleus j'imagine qu'on leur a posé
une question en conférence de presse
cette semaine les Bleus veulent qui pour
ces huitièmes de finale
alors
si vous voulez de la langue de bois je
vais vous en donner les Bleus ce qu'ils
veulent c'est ils s'en foutent ils sont
ils sont prêts à jouer contre n'importe
qui en se préoccupe pas de l'adversaire
il y a pas voilà en gros eux c'était on
prendra qui vient et c'est tout après on
imagine bien qu'il préfère peut-être
jouer un match face une équipe plus
tranquille d'abord avant de jouer
forcément voilà peut-être que
l'Argentine même si ça leur a bien
réussi à 4 ans donc pourquoi pas le
refaire mais voilà je peux pas vraiment
certain et au niveau des pronos moi je
suis pas certain non plus qu'on va
tomber pour l'Argentine je pense que
l'Argentine risque de gagner et le
Mexique ou l'Arabie Saoudite risque de
terminer le deuxième mais je serai pas
trop dire qui parce que le Mexique ils
ont quand même pas montré grand chose
depuis le début de cette Coupe du Monde
et l'Arabie Saoudite il va falloir qu'il
refasse à demi-exploit pour passer
merci Vincent reste ensemble je voulais
finir avec les notes m'ont donné
Christophe et Baptiste qui sont au stade
vous auriez donné combien c'est
tellement mandats allez et puis je
compare avec ce qu'ils nous ont dit ok
si le capte bien une tête de Slimane le
Rennais peut sans doute faire mieux sur
le but des ailes de Carthage c'est vrai
que c'est pas une frappe
bon vous les trouvez un peu sévère Axel
dit assis Dissy combien 4 je pense que
bien vu 4 4 pour le Monégasque Raphaël
Varane
4 4 et 4 aussi pour Raphaël Varane
quelques relances un peu mal assuré pour
le manque Unia et ce n'est pas dans ses
habitudes il est croqué par quasi sur le
but tunisien Konaté
parce que Baptiste et Christophe lui
donne 7 quelle activité alors que
l'équipe de France prenait la marée en
début de match se défenseurs centrales
de Liverpool était partout puissant
toujours bien placé souverain dans les
airs et c'est ce que nous disait il y a
un instant Vincent tiens alors c'est un
cas qui divise edwardo camavinga selon
vous combien y a-t-il donné 5 5 parce
que il fait un match en demi-tonnes donc
six bon moi je dirais ouais 5 et demi
alors ils seront dur avec lui il donne
trois entame de match excessivement
compliqué pour le madrilène qui mérite
toute
lamentuétude du monde pour avoir des
pannes à gauche oui c'est la première
fois qu'il doit un match latéral gauche
en tant que professionnel
Vincent vous l'avez trouvé comment vous
Kama vinga c'est dur 3 enfin vous étiez
au stade donc vous le savez mieux que
nous devant la télé ok il n'a pas été
transcendant
alors je vais pas déjger mais mes
confrères des sports avec qui je suis ça
risque de mettre une vraie ambiance mais
en trois vraiment le début de match de
kamalinga ça a été un enfer un vraiment
il a pris un petit pont il arrivait même
pas techniquement quand il avait le
ballon il n'était pas du tout à l'aise
il a fait des mauvais choix il voilà il
arrivait à rien en 20 minutes je pense
que au bout de 20 minutes on peut lui
mettre un et après il remonte quelques
points et du coup il arrive il arrive à
trois parce qu'il fait bon match
derrière mais ça me paraît pas non plus
fou enfin ça me paraît pas non plus
complètement délirant de le mettre trois
je souris devant ce que me disent nos
internautes Fred perso je m'en tiens au
résultat de TF1 superbe 8 de Griezmann
voilà tiens on continue sur les notes
allez on passe au milieu de terrain
Youssouf Fofana combien vous lui auriez
3 justement à deux et d'un million trois
voilà ils ont mis la même note à fauf
bien plus enfin le but
3 Cavavin gars mais on met deux à Fofana
va avoir même un ennemi parce que c'est
je vois pas ce qu'il a fait de bien
autant en tant que ma vinga on se donne
période on peut dire qu'il a fait une
seconde période plutôt neutre sans sans
éclat mais sans faute
c'est compliqué à noter effectivement je
vais faire un quatre et demi voilà
il a eu trois Kingsley coman voilà dur
la note basse C3 visiblement pour Kama
vinga Fofana coman Randall Kolo combien
vous lui
intéressante Vincent a très bien résumé
son match tout à l'heure en disant que
il avait été intéressant on avait bien
vu en première période et puis là il a
complètement disparu en seconde un peu
paradoxalement puisque c'est là qu'il y
avait les meilleurs renforts à ses côtés
moi je mettrai quatre et demi bon ils
ont mis quatre Arendal colomani c'est
dur je trouve dur sur certains et
ça passe
avoir eu aux honneurs
tiens il y en a un qui n'a pas eu de
note Didier Deschamps vous lui donnez
combien au sélectionneur Vincent tiens
vous pensez qu'il a fait les bons choix
qu'il a eu raison de faire tourner cette
équipe est-ce qu'ici il l'a fait tourner
il a bien fait tourner pas trop j'ai
l'impression allez moi je
moi je vais être provoque le but c'était
quoi de pas avoir de blessé c'est gagner
il a eu une valeur 7
je vous reconnais bien là vous êtes
provoque et ça vous fait sourire en plus
Teddy dites-moi quelle note vous donne
un échange bien sûr après après le match
il a lui-même déclaré qui voilà je sais
pas s'il a été trompé s'il a avoue que
c'était trompé mais
je pense qu'il a dû regretter certains
choix qu'il a fait et moi je l'aurais
pas donné la moyenne et puis enfin c'est
pas par rapport à ce match là mais par
rapport à sa liste en fait parce qu'au
final il y a pas de la conséquence sur
ce match la conséquence et au final ce
enfin la compétition la grande
compétition sanctionne les erreurs qu'il
a pu faire avant donc notamment tu vas
prendre de latéraux hein de latéraux et
même des milieux de terrain peut-être
plus créatifs et moins
vous lui donnez combien sur ce match
trois trois ah oui je veux être le
saquer un peu des champs Mathieu
Deschamps
c'est la rentrée de match c'est très
compliqué puis après avec les
changements
de Saint-Cyr et avoir fait les plus
grandes écoles de foot pour mettre
Mbappé Griezmann et c'est plus facile
quand on a ce genre de joueurs sur le
banc bon au final 4 et demi c'est Cédric
disait Deschamps vous l'adorez vous le
détestez sur ce match je vais déjà je
sais que Vincent rose prend soin de mes
collègues au Qatar donc je vais
totalement solidaire dans 1111 je lui
mettre 7 à Didier parce que l'objectif
est rempli ah non mais si maintenant
l'objectif pour un match de Coupe du
Monde c'est pas avoir de blessé bon on a
perdu mais Didier Deschamps a eu cette
feuille vous me racontez n'importe quoi
je suis pas certain de vous reprendre
sur place c'est le seul donc le garde
merci beaucoup Vincent quel est le
programme pour vous ce soir c'est
toujours galère parce que le match est
pas trop tard mais vous me dites quand
les matchs sont à 20h heure français
donc 22h au Qatar vous rentrez à 3h du
matin c'est une galère comment ça se
passe explique-moi un petit peu votre
vie sur place après les matchs parce que
ça nous étonne toujours cette cette
configuration
Qatar
alors c'est une galère on va pas non
plus se plaindre de notre situation bien
évidemment mais effectivement on est sur
des matchs qui sont assez tard donc 22h
22h minuit et ensuite il faut quand même
travailler sur place avant de partir
puis ensuite prendre le bus qui nous
ramène au centre des médias et ça c'est
un stade qui sont quand même assez loin
on dit que tous les stades sont à côté
mais il y en a quand même certains qui
sont assez loin et ensuite sont des
médias jusqu'à l'hôtel voilà vous avez
notre programme de soirée donc voilà on
rentre à cet art mais c'est on l'aime
bien ce petit programme cette petite
coupe du monde avec tout à disposition
merci beaucoup salut Vincent on se
retrouve très vite
dimanche évidemment pour l'avant match
le débrief à la mi-temps
de presse des blogs vous faites des
directs avec Baptiste et Christophe
évidemment et des petits reportages vous
m'avez dit que vous alliez essayer de
suivre des supporters français avant la
fin de la semaine pour voir quelle est
leur quotidien là-bas merci Monsieur
Teddy merci Mathieu merci Cédric merci à
vous tous de nous avoir suivi vous étiez
nombreux aujourd'hui sur Youtube et sur
le Figaro.fr on espère vous retrouver
évidemment
sur le Figaro life pour toutes les
autres actualités et puis dimanche on
suivra ce 8e de finale de l'équipe de
France nous n'avons pas encore
l'adversaire mais on le saura tout à
l'heure aux alentours de 22h merci de
nous avoir suivi on le félicite pas les
Bleus cette fois excellente soirée sur
le figure live